mogadishu smart teeny hospital which
dates back to the Italian colonial era
is Somalia's only medical facility
dedicated to treating its growing number
of Khurana patients due to its limited
capacity the hospital only caters for
the sickest of patients these doctor
runs the task force that is leading
Somalia's response to the pandemic at
least 218 patients of corona have come
to Martini hospital since the outbreak
21 of those were admitted to the few
bids available 17 people are still here
while 3 patients died at the hospital
it's hard to tell the severity and
spread of the virus in Somalia until
recently the nation lacked the
capability to test for the new virus
meaning samples were sent abroad and
results delayed for more than a week
these also limited capacity by the
government to trace people the first
victims of the virus came into contact
with the good news however is that four
people have so far recovered from the
virus Bashir Aden is one of them
I was provided good care by the doctors
and the nurses from the day it was
confirmed I had the virus they also gave
me good counseling when they broke the
news to me so I was mentally prepared
for everything I went through all
international domestic flights except
for emergency medical and food cargo
have been suspended the borders have
also been closed as part of an all-out
government effort to stop the spread of
the disease a massive public awareness
campaign has also been mounted in the
capital and in the media we're
encouraging people to practice social
distancing we're also alerting them
about what the virus is and the effect
it can have as well as the importance of
washing their hands and disinfecting any
equipment they're using beyond the
capital though al-shabaab fighters hold
sway in many parts of rural Somali this
means there is little access for medical
and humanitarian workers to carry out
life-saving work al-shabaab fighters
also carry out frequent attacks in the
capital and other major cities something
else that hinders
a proper response to the outbreak they
are now increasing fears that the
disease will spread through comes
housing displaced families who huddle
under Hut's built from sticks and old
rugs many of the 2.4 million Somalis
displaced by conflict and other
disasters over the years living comes
like this one a critical shortage of
medical supplies and personnel also
continues to grip hospitals across the
nation with some doctors and nurses now
saying they're increasingly being forced
to choose between the health of their
patients and their own Mohammed o al
Jazeera